time travel in Attack on Titan explained
part 2 during the final season Zeke took
Aaron into their dad's memories and one
thing that might have been confusing
about this is that it looked as if they
physically traveled back in time however
we need to understand that this wasn't
time travel but rather they were just
witnessing old memories of things that
had already happened this means they
shouldn't have been able to influence
the pause because the people they were
looking at were basically just Holograms
the only reason Aaron was able to
communicate with Grisha is because of
the attack Titan's special ability but
if any other character had tried the
same thing it would have literally been
impossible